what can I do with this we're always
there there's like there's like maybe
two lines to go and we're pretty much
there to get the relationship between
theta and alpha any suggestions oh yeah
I can rush what do you see uh-huh okay
now just before Raj goes on seeing angle
AOC on that side not a particularly
technical or or an ambiguous or clear
way of saying it um may I see the angle
that Raj is talking about is very
helpful how would you refer to this
angle AOC
in that it's different to this angle AOC
this angle over here
it's an obtuse angle isn't it at least
that's the way we've drawn it okay that
makes the angle on the other side not an
obtuse angle it's going to be a reflex
angle okay so you would actually name
that you would say reflex angle a Oh see
that's the way you would actually refer
to that angle it's a little bit awkward
but there's no other unambiguous way
that's succinct it's certainly better
than saying on that side so now Raj tell
us what you were going to say about this
angle this angle here is Roger
suggesting that's two theta
and another color how does that work
what's gone on there it is two theta but
can you see why let me highlight it for
you a little bit remember you told me
that angle the regular angle AOC is
double angle ABC because the angle at
the center standing on the same arc over
here on this side ABC alright well have
a look you've actually got the same
relationship over here it just looks
weird because it's sort of inside-out
the arc we're referring to is our stuff
from this way is arc ad see if I by the
way I call it ABC I gave you three
points so you know it goes around this
way rather than that way you can call it
arc AC because that's the beginning and
the end but how would you distinguish
that arc
a see from this arc AC it's very simple
of this isn't it right you have to
actually say something so one is a big
one and what is a small one so we would
call this the major this is actually
worth writing down the major arc AC as
opposed to the minor arc AC so there's
the minor arc AC this is the major one
okay so can you see that angle ABC
stands on this red arc stands on the
major arc and a OC is the same it also
stands on that arc once at the
circumference once at the center so
that's why I just got it he's now that
that's two theta okay we're almost there
what's the relationship now I was trying
to find this that's what I was setting
out to find how am I gonna do it two
theta two alpha they are angles at a
point right so therefore I can write 2
alpha plus 2 theta equals 360 degrees
okay
now I only introduced alpha to make this
a little bit easier to work with I want
to find out what alpha is so how do I
make alpha this object what will I do
here C alpha equals so I'm going to
subtract yeah that's a that's a theta
let me make a bigger tail better okay
I'm a better a little more obvious I
will point out the textbooks often write
theta like that that's often how they
write it like how it's tight but anyway
there's my theta so now what I do
I'll just just / - right so what does
this tell us where's this tell us I can
get rid of alphas now I don't need any
office here it's going to be here 180
degrees - you know so alpha is the and a
start of s what is it
it's the supplement of theta right if
you have a cyclic quadrilateral then the
opposite angles will always be
supplementary okay I guess I could have
said it like this alpha plus theta has
to equal 180 degrees that that's what
supplementary means okay so therefore
the property get out of this there
four and now that we've proved this we
can quote it anytime we like opposite
angles in what kind of shape is this
it's a cyclic quadrilateral it's not
just any quadrilateral all the points
are cyclic opposite angles in a cyclic
quadrilateral ah what was the
relationship they add it away
so that's solitary okay
lovely now the next property we're gonna
prove is so brief that we're going to
use the same diagram in fact I only need
to put in a tiny little thing here cm
angle ADC is what we found out was the
the supplement of angle theta over there
so what I want you to do is why don't
you take interval or the chord ad this
guy down the bottom take this chord and
I want you to extend it in mathematics
and you take it interval you make it a
bit longer we have a special day for
that we say we produce ad and we're
going to make it just a little bit
longer so let's produce ad out a point
like this let's call that e I guess if
you produce ad out to e then can you
tell me what this new angle is that
we've formed here C de what's its size
it's just Peter isn't it it's just there
why is that because what what's the
relationship between these two English
they are angles on a straight line right
and angles on a straight line as we know
add up to 180 degrees so therefore
there's this nice sort of matching
relationship here now how would you name
this this angle C D E what kind of an
angle is it it's not inside the
quadrilateral is it so it's a it's an
exterior angle right now we know
properties mat exterior angles to
remember this one if you've got some
angle x over here and you've got a and B
over here in a triangle then the
property that we associate with this is
the exterior angle of a triangle equals
what
it's the song it's the son of the
opposite to interior angles please mark
by the way don't say this angle equals
the opposite two interior angles it
doesn't equal I mean they're not even
equal right so it equals the sum X is
equal to a plus B right well in a cyclic
quadrilateral the exterior angle does
something different this exterior angle
is equal to it's not being equal to the
sum of anything what's it equal to the
opposite and this one that is on the
inside the opposite interior angle so we
can we can write that runner here it
didn't take much really effort
most of this was the work the exterior
angle of a cyclic quad cyclic
quadrilateral equals why don't we just
call that guy theta it's the opposite
interior angle that's nice